la CMP sur le zéro artificialisation net
autrement dit Lausanne deviennent se
conclure et se conclure positivement et
c'est une nouvelle très importante pour
nous sénateurs les républicains en
particulier et surtout très importantes
pour tous les élus de France en ce sens
que cet objectif d'usane de réduire de
50% le rythme de consommation aux
espaces naturels agricoles et forestiers
pour atteindre le zéro compensé en 2050
et quand même une très grande contrainte
pour les territoires qui continuent de
se battre pour continuer à loger nos
concitoyens à sauver du commerce en
centre bourg en centre-ville tout cela
interroge toutes nos politiques
publiques puisqu'on nous demande de
faire toujours plus avec deux fois moins
de fonciers nous sommes pas d'accord
depuis le début au Sénat sur la méthode
qui nous est proposée par le
gouvernement qui est beaucoup trop
descendante nous voulons depuis le début
que ce soit ascendant qu'on fasse son
territoire nous avions obtenu un droit
de proposition pour faire de la
territorialisation ce qu'il y a pas un
territoire qui ressemble à l'autre il
faut différencier notre propre approche
comment dire faire confiance aux élus ce
qu'il n'y avait pas dans les textes
depuis la loi climat et résiliente ce
qu'il y a dans notre texte notre
proposition de loi transpartisane et qui
permet de redonner de la liberté de la
confiance du temps des moyens des outils
aux élus pour qu'ils arrivent à
concilier le climat et le maintien d'une
activité d'un développement d'une
attractivité d'un territoire cette CMP
conclusive est évidemment une étape
importante attendue par tous les élus de
France mais elle appelle d'autres étapes
nous travaillons d'ores et déjà sur des
textes que nous déposerons à la rentrée
sur les nouveaux outils d'aménagement du
territoire et sur les nouveaux
financements une nouvelle fiscalité pour
porter la transition écologique qui
auront vocation à être discutées dès le
mois d'octobre et dès le prochain projet
de loi de finance donc le combat
continue